[Musique]
les sociaux-démocrates et l'union
chrétienne démocrate au coude à coude
cette fois il n'y aura pas deux mais
trois partis qui vont mener l'allemagne
deux possibilités la coalition feux de
circulation avec olaf scholz le rouge du
spd à le verre des écolos et le jeune du
fdp libéraux des files d'attentes de
plusieurs centaines de mètres un peu
partout au royaume uni les
automobilistes se précipitent dans les
stations essence par peur d'une pénurie
aussi non la coalisation de la coalition
jamaïcaine alors oui c'est vraiment
comme ça qu'on l'appelle parce que les
couleurs des partis rappelle le drapeau
jamaïcain et nury monstres causés par le
manque de chauffeurs poids lourds depuis
le break cité la pandémie 15000 aura
quitté le pays dans les magasins les
rayons se vident les fruits les légumes
et d'autres aliments du quotidien se
font de plus en plus rares il a fait
irruption en quelques heures ce mur
baptisées mur de la honte par les
habitants de pantin a été construit à la
hâte par la préfecture de police de
paris
quelques parpaings pour empêcher les
consommateurs de crack d'entrer dans la
ville des toxicomanes relocaliser dans
ce square parisien depuis la semaine
dernière est un symbole d'échec ce mur
ce mur est le symbole d'une forme
d'impuissance de l'action publique en
particulier de la delà de la les dires
du penchant exclusivement sécuritaire
qui a été donnée à l'évacuation de
riquet c'est une solution forcément
transitoire ça ne peut satisfaire
personne on est là dans une espèce de
d'urgence il faut répondre pour le
moment dans l'urgence cinglant revers
pour ségolène royal l'ancienne candidate
à l'élection présidentielle a perdu son
siège au sénat hier soir elle a été
sévèrement battu à l'élection des
sénateurs représentant les français de
l'étranger
elle a eu 11 voix sur 33 possibles quand
la gauche est divisée malepère voilà
parti socialiste avait décidé de mettre
un candidat contre moi il est notre
candidat donc ça faisait quatre listes
de gauche
voilà nous n'aurions pas fait ces aides
vous auriez eu des entreprises en
faillite et vous auriez eu des salariés
au chômage et aujourd'hui nous serions
en train de dépenser encore plus
d'argent
pour essayer de sauver des gens qu'on
aurait laissé tomber dans le désarroi
donc j'assume pleinement cette méthode
encore un mariage qui dégénère ça s'est
passé samedi dans le val d'oise selon un
journal local les invités auraient
bloqué l'autoroute a16 puis aurait
bloqué une départementale si tu as un
truc à dire qu'ils viennent d'un autre
phrase du jour est signée emmanuel
macron un étudiant de 19 ans a lancé un
neuf aujourd'hui sur le chef de l'état
qui déambule et vous le voyez dans les
salon international de la restauration
c'est là que la situation a dégénéré les
individus sont devenus agressifs ils
s'en sont pris aux gendarmes qui ont dû
utiliser du gaz lacrymogène regarde
l'une des chaises ont été jetés sur les
gendarmes les voici je cite notamment
évidemment l'une de vos proches votre et
nièces marion maréchal qui se dit proche
des idées d'eric zemmour je ne
m'aventurerai pas à dire que le scénario
du second tour est joué le doute hélas
le président du d'un groupe de chochotte
vous faites partie d'une famille de
chochotte en fait selon les propres
termes d'eric zemmour monsieur abad pas
écouté je pense pas qu'on soit chochotte
quand on voit toutes les propositions
qu'on a fait à l'assemblée nationale sur
le séparatisme la lutte contre
l'islamisme radical
moi je m'aventure m lapix je m'aventure
parce que je suis sur le terrain parce
que j'entends les français parce que je
sais que nous avons un projet qui est
cohérent global qui touche à l'ensemble
des aspects qui sont des sujets de
préoccupation majeur pour nos
compatriotes dont bien sûr l'immigration
qu'est ce qui se passe en france
agricole et moi je ferai pas de c'est
pas mon rôle de faire de commentaire
politique il veut s'allier avec
l'extrême droite et bien voilà donc nous
nous éliminer 1 6 ne nous ont pas
écoutés je sais que je vends bfm tv
n'est pas est morte et verront peut-être
parler de ma candidature n'empêche
parler de ce que je veux point
est ce que vous l'avez regardé
oui pas